including this one as kevin durant runs  into him smart falls down  [Music]  durant did not like the call  and lipson says that's not basketball  and i've been around basketball for a  long time that's basketball pulls from  micah  good point how many times did you get  that at home  oh they overturned it after review  successful challenge  overturning the call to a blocking foul  since the ball was not released it's  away from the play fire one shot and the  ball  wow that is a huge  call again because the foul comes before  the inbound pass away from the play  states one free throw and possession  i'm trying to figure out how do you take  a look at that and come away from it  thinking  that's a foul on marcus smug  [Music]  great challenge though and they get that  timeout back so they still have a  timeout remaining  [Applause]  durant cadets six point game  and it's brooklyn's possession  [Applause]  that's the internal eye roll